put that in context for us your one
millionth wallet what does that mean
exactly
good morning thank you guys so much for
having me on surveilling this the true
pledge would be here Tom I don't know if
you check the price of Bitcoin today yet
but it might have been wise to buy some
before the holidays anything that deep
it's on yeah man so is the world's
premier Bitcoin wallet and were the
first online only wallet to reach 1
million users now this is a historic
accomplishment never have we seen so
much traffic move into a Bitcoin wallet
and it's a real validation for the
entire industry and States
Charles is it a validation well anytime
you get a million downloads that's
progress no question about it
I still think there's some questions
about the business model and the need
for it your biggest question in we have
a pretty good currency system as it is
is this the biggest problem in these
well and that goes to the heart of it
Nicholas carry state for me the
efficiencies gained by betty-lou having
a Bitcoin wallet versus US dollars
though there are plenty of efficiencies
to be gained but in terms of how our
business model works block 219 so is a
100 percent Bitcoin only business so we
do our deals in Bitcoin we pay our
employees in Bitcoin and the entire
company operates that way but here's an
example this fall we sold advertising on
blockchain team so we have hundreds of
millions of views a month and we sold
that advertising for Bitcoin now the
price of Bitcoin went up fivefold since
then which made our deal even more
valuable but what a special position
unlike other businesses Nick is that how
you make money you make money by
advertising is that your business model
yeah we're one percent free service so
anybody around the world can sign up for
a Bitcoin wallet and there's absolutely
no cost to them and that allows them to
send Bitcoin to and from anyone anywhere
on planet earth for no fees basically
and we're free service Nick I think we
have a chart of just the growth you know
up to your one millionth and you know
this growth no surprise has really been
within the last 18 months or so and any
time that somebody looks at a chart like
that they think gee are we here getting
into a speculative bubble what what's
your argument that this is not
well there's an old progress I like
which is the best time to plant the
trees was 20 years ago
and the second best time to clean the
tree is today Bitcoin is absolutely in
its infancy still and last year we've
seen a lot of maturity in the space new
investments and lots of big companies
moving in but we're going to see even
more maturity and this year is going to
be huge the amount of energy and
optimism and intellectual capital moving
into bitcoin is astronomic and you're
right we have seen parabolic growth but
we're seeing things accelerate and move
more quickly the total number of Bitcoin
users in the world is unknown let's
watch a project like blockchain dot info
lead the way and get 1 million users
shows that there's real value for
companies to get into this space and I
anticipate more and more money moving
into it I mean Charles does it smell
like this is a trend that's going to go
from the fringes into the mainstream I
don't see it yet touching the mainstream
but you know this early or when you're
in life cycle was what's going to happen
next but I think it's a challenge
process model Nicolas you hear the
skepticism of mr. Phillips we had a
former CEO of PayPal just outright
hogwash
a few days ago on Bloomberg surveillance
within that do you think there is an
underlying theory and structure that
benefits even sustains the efficiencies
from what you're doing yeah for the time
being in a lot of ways that's true I
thought that interview as well and I
obviously have a different opinion than
he does but realistically in the next
year you have a lot of obligations for
software companies to build amazing
technology that's easy to use there was
a real tip of the spear in Bitcoin in
the last 18 months we had a lot of
people that were tech forward and the
next group of adopters are going to be
regular folks that just want a more
convenient way to make transactions
happen especially online where instead
of having to submit all of your private
information you'll be able to just make
a payment and get your goods and
services without having to pay these two
credit card companies so there are
definitely efficiencies to be had and I
think for the whole industry the
challenge is to grab that mind share and
the market share by creating amazing
software that's easy to use and that's
one of things we're going to do a
blockchain